phil how much do you worry about your
ideas being stolen
i don't really worry about them to be
honest um
i'm probably contradicting myself by not
revealing an idea i said earlier
when you ask me a question but that's
because i feel like they're not ready to
be heard yet
um
i think
i think people can
it can hold people back you know i i
mean and maybe i'm
maybe i'll eat my words and maybe i'm
being naive but i think this idea that
um
someone's going to read your script
steal it
and then write their own thing is kind
of a bit absurd because it's like
you know
if they liked it enough to want to steal
it why would they start again you know
it's like
at worst they would bite off you and you
would never hear from them again and
then and then they would go and make it
the film they want to be
you know for
x amount of dollars you know whatever
that is but this idea that
um i think that the big corporations the
students are apt to steal ideas and and
you know and not let us in or not help
us i think is uh
um
is is
is not very productive i think it stops
people
again it's the whole thing about putting
yourself out there right how people are
gonna know you've got that great script
if you don't share it you know like how
and you can protect it it's very easy to
copyright things and
you put in an envelope and post it
yourself all that kind of stuff that
people say you can do
but um
it's you know from everyone i've met all
the execs
uh development people studio heads and
things like that that want to make film
like they just genuinely want to meet
talented people right because talented
filmmakers and writers are going to make
great movies and make make hopefully
money and art you know so
why would you want to steal it i don't i
just it makes no sense i mean
um
you know you may be on a
maybe there might be a case in a smaller
level like you've got an idea for a
short film and then someone else
takes that and makes the short film i
mean i guess that could be very very
frustrating but
um
you know this is the business of
collaboration you can you just cannot do
this by yourself
so you've kind of got to let people in
there's got to be
there's got to be a certain amount of
trust
you know involved and you know as
someone that has been stabbed in the
back and someone that has
you know um
been the victim of certain things um
they've never really been about
things being stolen it's been more about
other other things that can go on
so
i just i'd say don't let that hold you
back you know
send it out submit it to
competitions let friends read it let's
friends pass it to friends because you
never know you know you never know uh
the odds are already against you why
make it worse than
just doing this and not letting people
you know
see your work
just to play the devil's advocate what
if they don't have the talent you have
and and
there's a part of them that wishes they
did
but they have some access to money that
can make it
i think that's the part that that could
be scary they they see your vision they
see what you've done previously and they
go wow this guy actually has an
excellent idea
i want to do what he's doing
and i have someone who can
yeah and and uh that's that's very um
very good devil advocate to play um i
would hope that in that situation that
um
you know it's not just about an idea an
idea doesn't really exist until it's a
screenplay until it's cast until it's
shot until it's made you know there's a
heck of a lot involved in making that
great idea um
so
um it's it it
it's a tricky one because it's it's
about
what is the idea right is it like you
just pitching a film you know it's like
oh you it's a three sentence pitch well
i could give you or seven other people
that three sentence pitch and they'd
write very different screenplays like at
its core
you know it's it's the long line but
it's very very different that's not
saying that's not excusing kind of
stealing that but what i'm trying to say
you stumped me with that one no i see i
see where you're going it doesn't exist
until until it's really a screenplay and
hopefully no one would take it at that
phase either but
um
i think that's a fair
answer
i think it's um
um i i think
i think i would hope that
people like that in the world are few
and far between and again
maybe it's my optimism coming out here
but
um
i would hope that if someone
cares enough
to want to steal something it just
doesn't make sense why they wouldn't you
wouldn't be involved in that thing or
just to pay you off like why would you
risk that eventual lawsuit or that thing
by you know um
uh
by just stealing it and making it it's
like hope sure you bring people into the
fold or you buy it and let them go you
know
um which happens you know which happens
um
so
but i just
you know
it's hard because obviously there are
bad people in the world and it and it's
it's a tough industry and and you know
and
there are some charlatans out there
but
it's
i i there's so much else that's already
holding you back personally
professionally you know in terms of
obstacles you need to challenge like i
wouldn't
let that fear factor get in the way of
people
seeing or experiencing an idea because
on the flip side there could be that guy
or girl or whatever that has that money
that wants to make that film and you
just so happen to have the great skip to
the right time like it's
you know you can't have all your cards
close to your chest you've you've got to
go this is me you've got to go
this is what i want to do you've got to
go
you know you've got to set your store
out so people understand what you're
trying to do
and if they like it hopefully
that starts the conversation
um unless you're really hostile about it
and they want to steal it because they
don't like you but then just be
nice be nice
everybody
so then you don't know anyone who's had
their material stolen no i don't know
anyone that's had
material stolen no um
you read about it now and again in
trades of like
i sent this back in and then you
suddenly made this big film and it was a
huge success give me some money
and um
you know uh and then you know some sell
out courts and whatever you know
whatever happens to those ones but no
personally i don't know anyone that's
had
anything stolen um
you know on a
from a commercial perspective
sometimes you
you know you get a script from an agency
and you write a treatment a visual
interpretation of that and you think
that when you're writing like well no
one else has come up with this way of
making this and then you don't get the
job and then you see it and you're like
hang on
that's quite close to the bone here
but
how do you like how do you prove that
and also that's that's i mean that's
very different to
uh having a screenplay stolen or
something
and i'm sure maybe that some of that
stuff happens maybe your little ideas
are borrowed or um
maybe creative ideas become part of the
melting pot and then suddenly you make
it your own you know and and you
genuinely believe that it's your idea i
guess there's a danger in that
um
but no i don't know i don't know anyone
personally that's had anything stolen